eblé chérie je suis là ne t'inquiète pas
je vais toujours des cauchemars
vous souffrez peut-être encore du stress
post traumatique provoquée par
l'accident du bien de longer un
demi-hectare du cabernet là tu as du
pinot gris et de ce côté les repas de la
folie se lancer là dedans maintenant il
faut que tu prennes soin de toi mais on
offert un beau bébé
j'aimerais proposer un toast pour faire
honneur à ce jeune couple
soyez les bienvenus dans notre grande
famille vous connaissiez la famille qui
habitait ici avant les pauvres ils
n'étaient pas de taille
ça va
et ménez que ça va je t'assure elle
avait l'air d'être aussi des souhaitons
la bienvenue à esbly dans notre amour
transmettons notre force de vie à
lettres qui grandit on est parfois j'ai
l'impression que la grossesse va me
rendre complètement bernier je sens
comme une présence ici je crois que
c'est pas m'imaginer ce jeudi lei de
bain ils ont explosé je comprends pas tu
dois apprendre à écouter son intuition
c'est en sixième ce sont de vrais
hallucinations et qui se répètent quart
d'heure qu'est ce que c'est que ça pour
l'inspection protection mais contre quoi
les diables il s'est passé quelque chose
sur le domaine on a commis un crime si
effroyable qu'il a sali la terre 3 bien
non
ce n'est pas ce que vous croyez